so Chris who's up first well we have a
man who's worried about pandemics pretty
much his whole life he played an
absolutely key role more than 40 years
ago in helping the world get rid of the
scourge of smallpox and in 2006 he came
to Ted to warn the world of the dire
risk of a global pandemic and what we
might do about it so please welcome here
dr. Larry brilliant Larry thank you so
good to see you thank you Larry in that
talk you showed a video clip that was a
simulation of what a pandemic might look
like I would like to play it this gave
me chills let me show you a simulation
of what a pandemic looks like so we know
what we're talking about let's assume
for example the first case occurs in
South Asia it initially goes quite
slowly you get two or three discrete
locations then there'll be secondary
outbreaks and the disease will spread
from country to country so fast that you
won't know what hit you within three
weeks it will be everywhere in the world
now if we had an undo button and we
could go back and isolate it and grab it
when it first started if we could find
it early and we had early detection and
early response and we could put each one
of those viruses in jail that's the only
way to deal with something like a
pandemic I mean Larry that phrase you
mentioned that early detection early
response that was a key theme of that
talk you made us all repeat it several
times is that is that still the key to
preventing a pandemic Oh surely you know
when you have a pandemic something
moving at exponential speed if you miss
the first two weeks if you late the
first two weeks it's not the deaths and
the
illness from the first two weeks you
lose it's the two weeks at the peak
those are prevented if you act early
early response is critical early
detection is a condition precedent and
how would you grade the world on it's
early detection early response to covet
nineteen course you you gave me this
question earlier so I've been thinking a
lot about it I think I would go through
the countries and I've actually made a
list
I think the island republics of Taiwan
Iceland and certainly New Zealand would
get an A the island Republic of the UK
and the United States which is not an
island no matter how much we may think
we are we get a failing grade
I'd give a B to South Korea and to
Germany and in between so it's a very
heterogeneous response I think the world
as a whole is faltering
we are certainly not we shouldn't be
proud of what's happening right now I
mean we got the detection pretty early
or at least some doctors in China got
the detection pretty early earlier than
the 2002 SARS which took six months this
took about six weeks and detection means
only finding it but knowing what it is
so I would give us a pretty good score
on that the transparency the
communication those are other issues so
what was the key what was the key
mistake that you think the countries
that you gave an F to made I think fear
political incompetence interference not
taking it seriously soon enough it's
it's pretty human I think throughout
history
pretty much every pandemic is first
viewed with denial and doubt but those
countries had acted quickly and even
those who started so like South Korea
they could still make up for it and they
did really well we've had two months
that we've lost we've given a virus that
moves exponentially a two-month
headstart that's not a good idea Chris
no indeed I mean there's so much
puzzling informations still out there
about this virus um what do you think
the scientific consensus is going to
likely end up being on unlike the two
key numbers of its infectiousness and
its fatality rate so I think the the
kind of equation to keep in mind is that
the virus moves dependent on three major
issues one is they are not the the first
number of secondary cases that there are
when the virus emerges in this case
people talk about it being 2.2 2.4 but a
really important paper three weeks ago
in the emerging infectious disease
journal came out suggesting that looking
back on the wuhan data it's really 5.7
so for argument's sake let's say that
the virus is moving at exponential speed
and the exponent is somewhere between
two point two and five point seven the
other two factors that matter are the
incubation period or the generation time
the longer that is the slower the
pandemic appears to us when it's really
short like six days it moves like
lightning and then the last and the most
important and is often overlooked is the
density of susceptibles this is a novel
virus so we wonder how many customers
could it potentially have and as it's
novel that's eight billion of us the
world is is facing the virus that looks
at all of us like equally susceptible
doesn't matter our color or race or how
wealthy we are I mean none of the
numbers that you've mentioned so far are
in themselves different from many other
infections in recent years what is the
combination that has made this so deadly
well it is exactly the combination of
the short incubation period and the high
transmissibility but what you know
everybody on this call has known
somebody who has the disease sadly many
have lost a loved one this is a terrible
disease when it is serious and I get
calls from doctors in emergency rooms
and treating people and I see use all
over the world
and they all say the same thing how do I
choose who's gonna live and who's gonna
die I have so few tools to deal with
it's a terrifying disease to die alone
with a ventilator in your lungs and it
it's a disease that affects all of our
organs its respiratory disease perhaps
misleading makes you think of a flu but
so many of the patients have blood in
their urine from kidney disease they
have gastroenteritis they certainly have
heart failure very often we know that it
affects taste and smell the olfactory
nerves we we know of course above the
lung the question I have is there any
organ that it does not affect and in
that sense it reminds me all too much of
smallpox yeah so we're in a mess what's
the way forward from here
well the way forward is still the same
rapid detection rapid response finding
every case and then figuring out all the
contacts we got create new technology
for contact tracing we've got amazing
scientists working at the speed of light
to give us test kits and antivirals and
vaccines we need to slow down the the
Buddhists say slow down time so that you
can put your heart your soul into that
space we need to slow down the speed of
this virus which is why we do social
distancing just to be clear flattening
the curve social distancing it doesn't
change the absolute number of cases but
it changes what could be a mount fugi
like peak into a pulse and then we won't
also lose people because of competition
for hospital beds the people of heart
attacks need chemotherapy difficult
births can get into the hospital and we
can use the scarce resources we have
especially in the developing world to
treat people so slow down slow down the
speed of the epidemic and then in their
troughs in between waves jump on Double
Down step on it and find every case
trace every contact test every case and
then only quarantine
the ones who need to be quarantined and
do that until we have a vaccine so it
sounds like we have to get past this
stage of just mitigation where we're
just trying to take a general shutdown
to the point where we can start
identifying individual cases again and
and contact race for them and treat them
separately I mean to do that
the that seems like it's going to take a
step up of coordination ambition
organization investment that that we're
not really seeing the signs of yet and
in some countries can we do this how can
we do this oh of course we can do this I
mean Taiwan did it so beautifully
Iceland did it so beautifully Germany
all with different strategies South
Korea it it really requires competent
governance a sense of seriousness and
listening to the scientists not the
politicians following the virus of
course we can do this let me remind
everybody this is not the zombie
apocalypse it's not a mass extinction
event you know ninety-eight ninety-nine
percent of us are going to get out of
this alive it is not it is we need to
deal with it the way we know we can and
we need to be the best version of
ourselves both sitting at home as well
as in science and certainly in
leadership and might that be even with
pathogens out there in the in the future
like can you picture or describe it even
worst combination of those numbers that
we should be start to get ready for
well smallpox had a iron out of three
point four to four point five so that's
probably about right but I think this
this a coded will be but it killed a
third of the people but we had a vaccine
so those are the different sets that you
have but what I'm mostly worried about
and the reason we made contagion and the
virus that we was a fictional virus I
repeat for those of you watching that's
fiction
we created a virus that killed a lot
more than this one look at the movie the
movie contagion that has been trending
on that lately and you're a sizable yeah
right but we made that movie
deliberately to show what a real
pandemic looked like but we did choose a
pretty awful virus and the reason we
showed it like that going from a bat to
an apple to a pig to a cook to whether
Paltrow was because that is in nature
what we call spillover as though anodic
diseases diseases of animals spill over
to human beings and if I look backwards
three decades or forward three decades
looking backward three decades Ebola
SARS Zika swine flu bird flu West Nile
we can begin almost catechism and listen
to all the cacophony of these names but
there were 30 to 50 novel viruses that
jumped into human beings and I'm afraid
looking forward we are in the age of
pandemics we have to behave like that we
need to practice one health we need to
understand that we're living in the same
world as animals the environment and us
and we get rid of this fiction that we
are some kind of a special species to
the virus we're not mmm eventually
vaccines though do you see any
accelerated path to a vaccine I do I'm
really I'm actually excited to see that
we're doing something that we only used
to do and think of in computer science
which is we're changing what should have
always been or has always been rather
multiple sequential processes do safety
testing then you test for effectiveness
then for efficiency and then you
manufacture we're doing all three or
four of those steps in instead of doing
it in sequence we're doing in parallel
Bill Gates has said he's going to build
seven vaccine production lines in the
United States and start preparing for
production not knowing what the end
vaccine is going to be we're
simultaneously doing safety tests and
efficacy tests I think the NIH has
jumped up what I'm very thrilled to see
that and how does that translate into a
likely timeline do you think a year 18
months is that possible
well back then
Tony thought she is our guru in this and
he said 12 to 18 months I think that we
will do faster than that in the initial
vaccine but you may have heard that this
virus may not give us the immunity the
long-term immunity that's something like
smallpox would do so we're trying to
make vaccines where we add adjutants and
that actually make the vaccine create
better immunity than the disease so that
we can confer in me for many years
that's going to take a little longer
that's question Larry back in 2006 as a
winner of the TED Prize we granted you a
wish and you wished that the world would
create this pandemic preparedness system
that would prevent something like this
happening I feel like we the world let
you down if you were to make another
wish now what would it be well I don't
think we're let down in terms of speed
of detection I'm actually pretty pleased
when we met in 2006 the average one of
these viruses leaping from an animal to
a human it took us six months to find
that like like the first Ebola for
example we're now finding the first
cases in two weeks I'm not unhappy about
that I'd like to push it down to a
single incubation period it's a bigger
issue for me what I found is that in the
smallpox eradication program people of
all colors all religions all races so
many countries came together and it took
working as a global community to conquer
a global pandemic now I feel that we
have become victims of centrifugal
forces or in our nationalistic kind of
barricades we will not be able to
conquer a pandemic unless we believe
we're all in it together this is not
some Age of Aquarius or kumbaya
statement this is what a pandemic forces
us to realize we are all in it together
we need a global solution to a global
problem anything less than that is
unthinkable
now you pretend thank you so very much
thank you Chris
[Music]